I definitely feel like I'm being pulled
in a million directions the kids are in
school and we have another baby on the
way so moving to Chicago would have to
be like a long conversation and honestly
it might be my breaking point Kim
Kardashian admitting she has mixed
feelings about Kanye West's unexpected
announcement that he wants to
permanently move their family to the
Midwest so insane this all went down
months ago but we're just getting to see
it on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
I'm a little bit annoyed we have to talk
about this before Kim had a full-on
meltdown
she had a heart-to-heart with her hubby
to air out their differences the thing
that set me off was okay that should
have been a conversation before I see on
the Internet you're moving to Chicago I
find out no I told you that before we
had that conversation we already it was
a con any conversation I have is serious
I don't joke I don't play I did not
think that that'll be going to be
seriously so my bad for not taking you
seriously we move it to Chicago that's
the last day we're not gonna move full
time but we will have more time to spend
time because that's my home too despite
all that drama Kim is still standing by
her husband's side after the rapper
received backlash for his pro-trump rant
on Saturday Night Live I know that Kanye
is always gonna be Kanye and I'm never
trying to change that I mean that's who
I fell in love with and I'm not trying
to change who he is
[Music]
during a family dinner Kim received some
unwanted opinions about why Kanye
spazzes out I don't know if L invite us
back ever did you do a rant at the end
at the end yes but the credits were
rolling like I can't control it
I just feel like to keep him calm you
really need to pay him a little more
attention and we're guessing there's
more Kanye to come this season earlier
this month Kim dish 2 et about finally
getting her hubby on the show in more
than cameos he couldn't be a long talker
yeah I know I just said bu we can edit
out the length and you know just say
whatever you want to say and he was like
what is this like an interview and I was
like no well just like you have to kind
of retell like what had happened and
like set the tone so that Nina the story
can make sense to some people if they
you know didn't catch everything that we
were filming it was like okay I got it